[Applause]
but I started realizing that family is
like you know that's why I'm trying to
repair excuse me
she's the one that showed up to the
other three
she's stubborn we're all stubborn you
already know that I can't even with you
she's all about family now
here left
I mean I know June loves the girls and I
hope everything works out great and
their relationship gets back together
but maybe she should have thought about
that when she told pumpkin hey adopt
Alana so I don't have to pay child
support
well I did too that's what June said she
was coming but no but you know I don't
know okay
[Music]
baby
where's the girls
where's the other ones okay
looks hyper alive
no it ain't no taking care of
I thought that you know having
they may not ever believe me they might
not ever trust me I don't know but I
mean and it is showing up it honestly is
a step in the right direction for mine
and her relationship to mend